it's not as big as react in Jango but
it's actually the little brother of D
Jango that nobody knows about kind of
like the little brother of Jonas
Brothers that nobody knew about so
that's basically flask I can't believe I
just like said Jonas Brothers talking
about
work hello hello everybody my name is
Nan I'm the black female engineer
provides content for new and aspiring
software engineers and welcome to my day
in the life I work at Dreamworks
Animation Studios I'm a software
engineer and I work on the production
engineering side of things and so what
my team does so think about movies and
DreamWorks in animation a lot of people
kind of stop at the idea of okay we have
animators then we have people just
putting everything together and then
boom we have Shrek but there's a lot of
iteration that that a lot of people kind
of leave out you don't just create Shrek
and call it a day you create a rough
sketch for the beginning days then you
kind of go in do some edits you send it
to people see what their comments are
get back to creating Shrek and that
constant rinse and repeat same thing
with shots and sequences and all of that
good stuff and so what we do is we
provide tools and software to make that
collaboration process just a lot easier
for teams and so think about college
when you had this team you were working
on a group project and all of y'all you
don't really want to keep on being the
same place and with the pandemic maybe
you couldn't even be in the same place
and so you may have relied on Google
Drive a ton Google Sheets Google Docs
all of that good stuff so that one
person or multiple people can be working
on the exact same thing everybody can be
looking at what everybody is working on
make comments make edits and keep on
that editing process and whatnot think
of some of our tools like that basically
this basically go Google Drive of okay
everybody can come together look at all
the different shots all the different
sequences all the different characters
made and whatnot make edits make
comments and go back to the drawing
board do what needs to be done and do it
all again upload or download or Draw or
all of these different things to make
collaboration just a lot easier so
really that's what we do we develop and
we maintain those apps sometimes the
apps are ours and we created them
sometimes the apps are third party and
we just maintain them or we enhance them
in some way by building upon those
features and what not and so it's very
exciting I have really enjoyed this team
and in my team everyone kind of has
their own project everyone kind of has
their own app they really focus on
rather than having one team where you
all work together constantly to develop
the same thing or to accomplish the same
goal us were're more separated out in
the sense that I haven't worked with
most of my team members it's a team of
about 9 10 of us and I have haven't
worked with most of them because they
work on other different apps that me and
them just don't really cross paths and
so what I work on or at least what I've
been working on lately I've only been
working here for like two months and so
what I've been working on lately is
building an app to maintain the
managerial tasks of teams it's making
sure that yeah those managerial tasks
can be done in kind of just one place
rather than kind of going all around and
talking to a bunch of people like hey
can you do this and can you do that and
I need this and I need that those
managers being able to do those things
on their own and so yeah throughout my
day you're going to see me go through
different meetings and whatnot and I'm
going to come back sharing more about
what I'm doing what I've been doing and
yeah so I'll see you
[Music]
soon okay so it is now lunchtime all
morning at I've been doing some
debugging it's like the issue isn't
really app related at all but it's an
issue nonetheless and so going to be
working this afternoon probably trying
to S side step do some uh little bit of
kind of I don't know hacking the system
a little bit to get everything up and
running the way it should be and so yeah
it is lunchtime I'm going to go and get
some I think California Pizza
Kitchen baby sh and come and save me i'
been missing lady look ever since she
started hating I've been waking up too
early I'm Miss crazy haes in the middle
of the night watch the stars from
different places and thees we call won't
start to change you ever wake up feeling
like everything strange you
one
St so we are back from lunch for the
rest of the afternoon sorry I'm still
like lunch brain for the rest of the
afternoon I'll be working on the app I
am you know building and you know
enhancing and whatnot for this project
I'm using Python and flask I had never
heard of flask before I don't know how
many of y'all have heard of flask before
but flask is a python micro framework
it's not as big as react on Django but
it's actually the little brother of D
Jango that nobody knows about kind of
like the little brother of the Jonas
Brothers that nobody knew about so
that's basically flask I can't believe I
just like said the Jonas Brothers
talking about work but yes that's
basically what flask is and it took a
little bit of learning it took a little
bit of getting used to but actually I
was able to pick it up pretty quickly
because of how micro it is as a micro
framework because of that it means that
you really don't need much to get things
up and running and there's a lot of
flexibility with it and so I actually
really like it I actually like it more
than I thought I would but I mentioned
to you all that I am very very new like
my two-month anniversary is coming up
and I'm honestly shocked that it's even
been 2 months at all because it feels
like 2 minutes and so I've had to
learned a lot I mentioned I'm building
in Python right now and that has been a
big uh like shift because I've never
used python before I primarily learned
through learning JavaScript and whatnot
I went to a coding boot camp and really
Focus was very JavaScript heavy that's
what I've built web apps with and so
when it comes to learning new programs
and languages and tools and whatnot
especially if you're in a new job or a
new boot camp and you're just trying to
learn things really quickly I really
recommend pair programming that's
actually helped me a lot in my learning
and I'd like to thank co- screen for
sponsoring this video co-c screen is a
screen sharing and collaboration tool
for like developers built by Developers
for developers and so I really love it
because they really just hit the nail on
the head knowing exactly what developers
need most especially with this whole
parent teacher conference going on for
the last 30,000 years and so it really
just makes that process of PA
programming a lot easier and a lot
smoother I'll link above a video where I
share more on pair programming and video
how best to yeah go about it so you're
getting the most you can out of it co-
screen also has low input latency which
really allows it to just perform
so so fast no matter how many users are
on a call 2 3 6 the world is your oyster
so knowing that you can work and not
experience that lag really just makes a
huge huge difference one of the things I
really love about Co screen is how easy
it was to get it up and running it Tru
took no time at all like maybe 3 minutes
maybe there are other tools to use for
pair programming like vs code and just
regular old Zoom sessions however with
this it makes the back and for fourth
that pair programing often entails a lot
more seamless because you can just grab
on to a person's screen and type things
out or fix typos or direct them and so I
really really highly recommend checking
out their site checking out the tool
itself it's free to use and so go in the
link below and check it out and actually
if you comment on this video I'm going
to select three people total to get a
lifetime access to co- screen where you
can just use it in all of its glory and
unlock all the amazing features it has
to offer and so make sure to do that as
mentioned I'm going to now do some more
app development for that managerial web
app I'm
building up with
you we got no plans we got nothing to
do you tell me you love me I go start
the
coffee Sunday morning easy love with you
okay
[Music]
okay so I used to think I liked front
end development
more however after spending like a solid
2 months not doing strictly just front
end I'm realizing I don't think I do
I think I like anything that has to do
more with just logic like creating the
functions and the functionalities and so
maybe so I like the maybe the JavaScript
portion of front end
development but I also like a lot of
backend development and that's what I've
realized because here I am trying to
style this web
page and I can't grab the looking here
cuz that's where my monitor is I can't
grab what I need to grab like it's not
doing what it needs to do it's not
giving what's supposed to give it's not
understanding the assignment and so
speak like I'm so frustrated and that's
what is really rough at front end
development so a lot of people
misinterpret
front-end so a lot of people
misinterpret front- end development to
mean only like oh you're just designing
the you know web app the app the page
Etc and calling it a DAT but like no
there's a lot of logic that goes into it
however there's also the designing
portion I think it's the designing
portion I'm starting to like not so much
because at least with the logic there's
the constant even if you're not getting
it even if you're not producing the
output you need to you're still just
constantly trying things out and
researching and doing all of these
things but front end I feel like it's
just so slow it's just so slow you feel
time so much more cuz here I am trying
to just make the width be like the page
size and it's just not doing it it's
like no 50px is all you get from me and
so it just feels so much slower to go
through it such a slower process and so
yeah that's something I've learned over
these last few weeks I don't think I'm
as ramped up about front end development
as I used to be
um yeah yeah okay
[Music]
anyway early 3:43 p.m.
PST I am in LA and yes I shared with my
mentor
how annoying CSS is
I like I said loved front end
development love it less so now and so
trying to I'm looking I'm looking up I
my monitor trying to see how best to go
about the rest of my time because at
5:00 I have a new higher bonfire if you
saw my Instagram you know that I was
sent a package of alcohol um alcohol and
a cocktail maker situation like a I
don't even what's the word like a
DIY cocktail so alcohol and I don't even
know was it like tonic water and a juice
and garnish ice um so they sent
everything you need and so I have the
new hire
bonfire today at 5:00 so about an hour
and 15 minutes and so in that time I'm
trying to see what do I want to do and
I'm truly thinking while I'm filming
what do I want to do so yeah we have a
new higher bonfire going on in about 1
and 1 half minutes I have a wine glass
because I haven't really done enough
apartment Furnishing to now get to the
cocktail uh glass part of things so
we'll be using this not really sure what
proportions to use these
ingredients with on what yeah uh so we
will try our best but other than that
we're at the end end of my day so thank
you all for watching and don't forget to
leave your comments below